صفحه مهمه في تاريخ الطيران المدني
والتجاري تطويها شركه بوينج عملاق صناعه
الطيران الامريكيه التحدث عن ايقاف انتاج
طائرات 747 المعروفه تاريخيا باسم جامبو
50 عاما مرت على انتاج الطائرات الاولى من
هذا الطراز تنتهي مع تسليم الشركه اخر
نسخه منها لشركه اطلس اير وفي المجموع
صنعت بوينج
2574 نسخه من الطائرات التي هيمنت على
الاجواء نهايه جامبو تاتي بعد انهاء
ايرباص الاوروبيه
بعد ان احدثت ثوره في عالم الطيران لمده
خمس عقود كامله هل يمكن القول اليوم فعلا
ان نعصر الطائرات الكبيره قد ينتهي هو
اليوم تعرف ان احنا الوقت الوقت مناسب جدا
لهذه الامور تصير بس ما ننسى كمان انه
بنفس الوقت وقت كانت هذه التيارات موجوده
كان الها عشره او كان الها عزه وكان لها
وقتها كان كثير ممتاز وكان جيد بهذا الوقت
هذا بس اليوم بتعرف نحن صرنا تابعين يعني
الاشياء اللي هي الاشياء اللي هي ممكن انه
تعطينا احسنتي وممكن يكون في مثلا عرفت
كيف اقل اقتصاديا احسن وافضل بس ما ننسى
انه نحن هذه الاشياء اللي الطائرات اللي
طلعت طلعت بوقتها وكان الها وقت مناسب
تعودنا عليه كانت موجوده بالسبب كان في
بيانو وكان في امورها يعرف كيف بس بعدين
وقت طلعت هاي اكتشفوا انه الشحن الجوي هو
اساس كل شيء فهلا اليوم يعني مقارنه مع
اللي هي موجوده بطيران الامارات سبعه سبعه
اليوم وسبب يعني الفرق بسيط جدا بالنسبه
للشحن يعني عندك طياره السبب فوق العملاق
اللي هي موجوده حاليا
اخر مده هي كانت يعني تقريبا على 128 طن
بينما
يعني ما في فرق كبير بالنسبه للاشياء
وعندك مجال اوصل اوسع اكثر
وتقريبا تجهيز المطارات الها اقل
من السبب
[موسيقى]